I just want you guys to hear this so I
can sort of break this last bit down
before we go move on to take some
calling stuff here
finals I'm making this video to
apologize
because I'm embarrassed and ashamed
because I lied and I misled a lot
I stated that this is a complicated
Topic at least to me it is because
before social media I was rich and
Anonymous and after social media I'm
still rich but no longer Anonymous so
like
foreign
he's trying to downplay it you know
before social media I was rich in a non
after social media I was rich and famous
and I didn't really want that
um he was a pharmaceutical sales rep his
wife was in dentistry
um they ran some sort of a Dentistry
business together
and then he got into supplements from
what I understand the supplements
weren't selling for when he got started
they weren't moving and he knew he had
to do something different if he wanted
to compete in the marketplace and what
better way to compete than build an
impressive physique go on podcasts and
talk about how your nine ancestral
tenants and eating balls and liver and
hearts will get you looking the way that
he's sitting there without his shirt on
but he just doubles down you know here
like this is this is this is weak and I
never expected this kind of exposure in
the public eye
okay
because in one of the emails that he was
exposed on he literally told the Bro
Science Guy what he was taking he also
said I have a team a film team and our
aim is to blow up our social media
presence to something like 1 to 1.6
million in the course of a year which he
actually did I think is uh Instagram's
like 1.7 million or something like that
like he blew it up very very quickly in
that short period of time so that was
the plan but he did you know there's lie
number two right there
has been tricky as [ __ ] to navigate
well
clearly I did it wrong and I'm here now
to set the record straight
yes I've done steroids and yes I'm on
steroids monitored and managed by
trained hormone clinician okay
so he's calling so like he's not being
clear like he should be saying it's
being monitored by a Bro Science Guy
basically because it's not a trained
hormone clinician okay I mean
okay maybe you could argue a
well-versed
Bro Science Guy is a hormone clinician
but not licensed like he's kind of
implying that the that the person
monitoring this is a licensed you know
when you say clinician
Letter King the public figure was an
experiment just for the message to bring
awareness to the 4 000 people a day who
kill themselves that 80 000 people a day
that try to kill themselves our people
are hurting at record rates with
depression autoimmune anxiety
infertility
um
so this is where he gets into some more
[ __ ] I did this to save people's
lives people committing suicide people
with low T people with autoimmune
disorders people with that you know that
were thinking about taking permanent
steps to a temporary solution in their
life I did it for them he put all that
[ __ ] in his ass the DECA the Winstrol
the testosterone the fifteen thousand
dollars a month in human growth hormone
he put all of that in his body just to
save you from doing something stupid to
yourself he did it all for you guys had
nothing to do with the supplement line
going on the podcast bringing his raw
[ __ ] and the supplements and talking all
the and like shaming all these guys that
that had them on had this guy and his
team on their podcast like all you had
to do was look at him be like yeah that
guy's on juice shut the [ __ ] up
Edition in life our young men are
hurting about feeling lost weak and
submissive so I made it my job to model
teach them yeah look you know here's a
good point like I wonder if you invested
any of the money that he made but
specifically into saving lives did he
create a foundation a non-profit you
know for people like that like he's
talking about infertility too was one of
the things that he mentioned and I don't
know if you guys know this but when you
take exogenous testosterone your own
body's production generally shuts down
when your exogenous levels are so high
because your body goes oh we got lots of
this stuff in the bloodstream we don't
need to make it anymore we're good and
as a consequence of that you're not stop
making sperm so she's talking about
solving infertility with his message
that's the truth of the matter is he's
creating his own infertility by taking
so much gear
preach a simple elegant solution oh and
by the way one of the compounds he was
taking was Deca and I don't know if
you've heard about this uh condition
called decadec but generally speaking
when you take nandra loan at the levels
he was talking about I don't know how
long he took it for but in that email it
indicated pretty significant levels Deca
is a great compound because it
lubricates your joints
um and it's highly anabolic too right
it's it's it's a very uh potent compound
for building muscle and a lot of older
older guys that power lift and body
build use Deca to lubricate their joints
so they don't have back pain shoulder
pain knee pain stuff like that but a
consequence of it is neanderloan creates
decadic uh so chances are liver Queen
wasn't getting serviced by Mr liver King
based on the dosages that I was looking
at there 9 successful tenants so our
people no longer have to suffer so we
can collectively express our highest and
most dominant form this is my fight this
is why I exist
so why didn't you do it without gear
then right
that's like the real question
while spreading the message I've been on
several podcasts and when asked if I'd
ever taken steroids I've always said no
I don't touch this stuff not going to
touch the stuff never touch the stuff
that was a lie
I'm convinced myself that this had
nothing to do with the ancestral message
I convinced myself that I'm not a
competitive athlete of any kind so who
the [ __ ] am I cheating I convince myself
that this topic was a placeholder for a
far more important conversation I
convinced myself that this would
overshadow the 36 years of working out
usually twice a day without Peds
I've convinced myself
that this was a vocal minority usually
in the fitness category driving to an
unproductive conversation I love that
driving it's like very intense very
serious
who else did that by the way
tell me in the comments tell me tell me
if there's any association that this
reminds you of because I've seen that
before
and I convinced myself
the wrong message to send to the 15 year
old boys
so I continually dismissed it and I dug
myself into a bigger and deeper hole I
have only myself to blame I did that and
it was all wrong I will be better I will
talk about it openly because I believe
that there's a time and a place for
pharmacological intervention monitored
and managed by a trained hormone
physician
in 2021 when I was hormone Physicians so
now he's talking about using a doctor
right he was talking about a clinician
before now he's talking about a
physician 43 years old
I didn't feel 100 physically
so I went to get monitored and managed
by a trained home clinician see what the
[ __ ] was going on with my life
and so yes it's true I have to it's
called andropause my friend as you get
older your testosterone levels drop
naturally that's why most guys that want
to operate optimally go on therapeutic
dosages of testosterone prescribed by a
doctor not the [ __ ] you were doing
you're doing bodybuilding dosages stuff
I tried several peptide combinations in
an effort to increase my growth hormone
and it didn't work meaning that my level
still remained below the normal lab
level so yes it's also true that I've
tried pharmaceutical grade growth
hormone and I finally found success
no try again try again he did this
during his speeches
in managing therapeutic levels in the
normal range
yes this is true I've continued on with
0.6 cc's of testosterone per week
roughly 120 milligrams of testosterone a
week and nope so so he says it was 120
milligrams of testosterone a week now I
don't know if I did the conversion wrong
when I when I did that tweet but when I
converted uh the amount of CC's that he
was taking in the email to IU's it it
converted for me at three and a half
times higher than what I was taking now
he's saying 120 milligrams which is
essentially a therapeutic testosterone
dose which is [ __ ] there is
absolutely no way that you can get that
big on a third like you'd have to be a
hyper responder like you'd have to be a
Ronnie Coleman to respond to that like
even even Coleman was not taking those
dosages like these Mr Olympia type cat
like dudes were in the 500 to 600
milligrams per week he's talking about
120 which I don't believe it I don't
believe it for a sec and it is you know
his email shows a lot of other stuff too
I don't take any other steroids like
Angelo and or Winstrol but I have tried
them in the past without success
[ __ ] it was in the email yes it's
also true that my blood chemistry got
all [ __ ] up while taking Angelo and
went strong okay now that information
hasn't been revealed yet I don't know if
Derek's gonna you know do that in the
next couple of days but he's obviously
preemptively talking about it at this
stage I love it got all deranged my
liver enzymes went Sky High which is why
clinical
correct
that was that was one of them there was
another guy that was part of the axis as
well
oversight
is it a company's we're already kicking
ass already successful before the
Liberty public figure
oh [ __ ]
dude the amount of podcasts you went on
and people were like oh you know how's
your supplement doing you know were the
you know are all these podcasts you're
doing helping is like no no we're still
selling 100 million dollars here then
why were you flying around in your
private jet with your [ __ ] weights
with your social media team putting
together all these reels and tick tocks
and YouTubes to to create clips of
yourself to drive traffic to all of your
[ __ ] why
liar growing at 50 you're over here and
still growing at the same Pace after The
Libertine public
nope I've never had AB implants AB
etching or any other plastic surgery and
I sure as [ __ ] never actually had Gene
editing done in Singapore I made all of
that up it was all intended to be a joke
and that's an expression of essential to
the 10 have a little goddamn fun
ultimately why did I or why do I do them
when I talk about the 85 percent of the
population that suffers from self-esteem
issues
there it is there's the other guy
right
I knew somebody was gonna pick it out
that's me I'm part of that statistic
this is why I [ __ ] work myself to
death in the gym this is why I do 12 to
15 blood burning more
just to feel like I'm okay still I have
to absolutely Crush myself to do so and
I'm right physically and cognitively in
hormone replacement has helped in a
profound
and still I believe that the Paradise is
paved in [ __ ] hell
he's right about that you know you're
gonna have to do hard work to get
somewhere just you lied about how you
achieved your results routinely over and
over again I previously have said in a
weird way I'm grateful for the recent
events that [ __ ] light on this
complicated this topic I knew I needed
to take this opportunity to openly
discuss
everything for me to be a better human
if there are any questions that will be
not answered in my way
I fully owned that I [ __ ] up I am
sorry as a man can be and all I can do
is take extreme ownership right now be
better and leave myself to a better life
as a better human again thank you to
everyone all right so that's enough of
that hey guys I really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out